that's an
unimaginably small number
what we have is zero point zero zero
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen seventeen eighteen 19 20 21 22
23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33
663 that's planck's constant and what
i'm leaving off are a load of other
decimals
a lot of other numbers here we've just
rounded that that up slightly h
conjures up quantum mechanics and it's
the constant of planck that tells us
that this is the
smallest amount of action that we have
now action is actually quite a dif
difficult concept planck's constant is
really it's a measure of quantization
it's something that comes up in quantum
mechanics and it's to do with the fact
that things in in the world when you
look on the small enough scale when you
look closely enough you find actually
they don't vary smoothly they don't vary
continuously they take on sort of
discrete values and so for example the
energy of light given out by atom it
doesn't give out light at all
frequencies it gives out light at very
particular frequencies and those
frequencies tend to be very close
together
but actually there's only particular
values of of energy that you can give
out and planck's constant is really what
dictates how close together those values
are planck's constant tells us about how
electrons orbit
atoms um i've wondered about h and i've
wondered about the physical significance
of h i've never quite wondered why hey
it's why it's called h or not w
again i ought to know it's a similar
question to see i i
um i don't know i don't know
by no way it's not called p because p is
conventionally used for momentum and one
of the key
equations relating
um
momentum and wavelength is this so we
couldn't call planck p as well so planck
was a very famous german physicist
considered by many to be the the sort of
godfather the forefather of of um
quantum mechanics do you write him oh
yes yeah i don't think there's a
physicist alive dead or to come that
wooden red plank so this is a second
year undergraduate experiment that is
actually used to
measure to work out what planck's
constant is
we have a mercury lamp here so with this
of a lamp which is full filled with
mercury gas and we're actually putting
electricity through that to generate to
excite the atoms
excite the electrons in those atoms and
those electrons bounce between different
states and they give off light and so
that's what we can see here is we can
see the light coming out from the
mercury
lamp then we've got a series of of
lenses
and um slits to really um
control how that where that light goes
so over here we've got a prism which
splits that light up into its
constituent colors now unlike sunlight
where you know if you take a prism and
you split that up you see a broad broad
spectrum
here what we have are very well defined
lines this is in effect a signature or
fingerprint
of mercury then what we do is we take
those spectral lines and have to move
this
take that we take those spectral lines
and what we have here
uh it would have been helpful if i set
it up can you just
you can just edit this can't you yeah
yeah so here we've with the prism we've
broken up the light into its constituent
colors
we really want to focus
um on one of those colors now and so
let's we're going to select the grain
we've got a slit here which selects the
grain out we've got a lens back here
which in turn focuses the light onto
this photodiode so we have green light
we have photons with a particular energy
coming into this photodiode and what's
inside this photodiode is a metal the
green light comes in it releases
electrons and from looking at the energy
of those electrons we can work out what
planck's constant is
that looks like ned kelly that diode do
you know who had kellies
i guess i never thought
quite that sense yeah
so h is equal to 6.63
by 10 to the minus 34 and my
first year on any undergraduate would
kill me if i didn't add the unit so
joule second now the reason that it
appears small to us is that we are very
large objects
you know we weigh 80 kilos whereas atoms
are something like uh 10 to the minus 27
kilos that's the mass of the proton the
electron is even lighter
and down at that scale the the units
that we choose to express h in uh become
a little bit cumbersome and inconvenient
so if we were working out these things
on atomic scales then
h would have a much more convenient
convenient and easily more easily
memorable value
so there's a really um fascinating story
called um well about a character called
mr tompkins which was written by a guy a
physicist of another very important
physicist called george gamma
back as i believe in the 50s
40s or 50s
and
he
mr tompkins is a bank manager who goes
along to various different
talks
by leading physicists and scientists of
the time
and he sits through the lectures on
invariably halfway through the lectures
he falls asleep and he has a dream and
the dream is usually related to the
topic of the lecture and one of those
very popular
mr tompkins stories relates to
what would happen if h wasn't this
imaginably small number what if it was
larger and if it were larger and it were
large enough so that we could see the
this quantum phenomena in the in the
real world
and that would mean that instead of
being sort of solid objects we would
have wave like characteristics so we
would spread out
if i were to for example to walk through
the door
because i'm now of wave like
characteristics i would diffract and so
bits of me would go in different
directions